[Music]
our breathing can deep and then become a
regular our heart starts to race our
pupils dilate which might be one of the
reasons so many people close their eyes
during active there are three sensations
that one should really recognize when
they're kissing first of all there's the
wonderful feeling of touch because our
lips are extremely sensitive we have
more nerve neurons on the end of our
lips than any other place in our body
with except some areas in our genitalia
and then of course also there's taste
each individual has a unique taste to
them and some people are much better at
recognizing tastes and others and then
of course is also smell of it and some
of his points talk about kisses smelling
like ripening apples in the chest
there's a lot of theories as to why we
kiss but some of it may have to do with
our earliest experiences on planet Earth
when we're infants through being kissed
by parents and also through nursing
through a lot of lip stimulation that
becomes associated through neural
pathways in our brain with these very
very positive emotions and so we're
building these neural pathways that
attribute kissing and lit stimulation
with love and security and all of these
wonderful things that later in life when
we want to express ourselves that way we
probably do so using our mouth while we
can't zip ourselves back in time and
kind of discover when and where and how
the first kiss took place among humans
what we do know is that other species
are very attracted to the rosy bottoms
of females when they're at peak
fertility when they're in estrus
there are some anthropologists that
think that the lips are what's called a
genital echo so they mimic the female
genitals and shape composition color and
texture and they serve as a reliable
indicator of when a woman might be ready
to mate Desmond Morris of British
zoologist he's actually done some
research on lipstick showing different
men images of women's faces asking who
the most attractive are and over and
over and over men are consistently
choosing the women who are expressing
the rosiest
most colored lips in the study so
there's something that does draw our
attention to the mouth and the color red
is a color that many species use to
exhibit this sexual signal the earliest
evidence that we find of any kind of
kissing is about 2,500 maybe 3,500 years
ago in some of the early Vedic texts
that come from India it turns out that
the area right below your eyes has
sebaceous glands that produce a unique
smell for each individual so these
ancient Indians in northern India or a
sniffing each other and as of course if
they ran their noses across the cheeks
of each other and then across the nose
to the other side of the cheek I think
that occasionally some of them slipped
and may have ended up on the lips and
because the lips are so sensitive they
may have found that that was much more
pleasurable than just sniffing each
other
the Romans can be looked upon really is
probably the first great kissing culture
they had different kinds of kissing the
sovereign was what we might call a
French kiss based on the court saliva
which we still use today and of course
they enjoy practicing this all the time
there's places where people just thought
cusing was disgusting which might not be
that surprising when you consider that
for the most part people weren't
brushing their teeth and flossing and
using mouthwash and all these things we
do today where it would probably be a
lot less appetizing not that long ago
however it's something that even where
we didn't do that when we're sniffing we
were patting we were licking and sucking
and nibbling and doing things all about
each other's bodies to connect and that
connection is ultimately important for
keeping us together for keeping our
bonds strong for raising all of the
different hormones and neurotransmitters
in our bodies that make us maintain our
important relationships and kissing is a
big part of that
[Music]